[Music]
[Applause]
let's bring in the popular rick stroud i
didn't think i'd be talking to rick
probably the rest of my life he covers
the buccaneers for the tampa bay times
host sports day tampa bay podcast i
think those were my last words to you
rick and here you are just like brady
you're back
if i would have asked you if i would ask
you
on friday
that tom brady is coming back or he's
going to stay retired what would you
have said
uh retired yeah yeah it's it's this
whole thing is weird man i can't get
used to the time change like it's jason
like savings time right now right i mean
uh
it's like 2020 like i woke up and and
they did it all over again right they
they got remarried um
you know there was always a chance right
i mean people i talked to close to brady
said give him give him 90 days well he
only needed 40.
and i don't think you know the timing is
not coincidental i mean you know we're
starting at noon today a period where
any team can reach a deal with any free
agent from another team and so you know
tom obviously wants to win if he wants
to win uh he's got to keep his guys in
we've already seen a deal done for ryan
jensen um which was probably a little
bit of a savings i think jensen could
have gotten 15 million dollars a year he
comes back for 13 million um and to play
with brady and you're going to see a lot
of signings i think uh really in the
next few hours even um for the bucks to
to retain as many of their guys as they
can and
of course they got the draft and their
own free agency to deal with
are you more surprised that he retired
or did a young retire
i think i was a little more surprised
that he retired and and it might have to
do with why he's not retired now and
that is dan he was playing as good a
football as he has ever played i mean uh
the tape shows it the arm strength was
certainly there he led the league in
passing you know 5 316 yards 43
touchdowns hell they should have won
that last game he brought him back you
know down 24 or whatever it was uh they
tie it up with under a minute to go and
if not for some really bad defense down
the stretch you know the rams kick the
field goal and win but if the bucks win
that game they're hosting san francisco
right and maybe they go on and win the
super bowl and i think tom realized that
uh and he said it i mean i don't know
what unfinished business you could have
but but he's he's found some and and i
think that he just felt like when he
gets to september he's gonna know he
should be playing football and you know
that decision needed to be made and it
needed to be paid you know before today
i wonder if he had won another super
bowl this past year
yeah that that would have been
the finality to this that he's always
going to have unfinished business unless
he wins the super bowl but then you know
that's where
you want to come back because you just
won the super bowl so it never ends
unless it's injury
but you know he's healthy and that's
what i wonder about how he comes up with
the
now i'm ready to retire
i i don't know and we we talked about
this when he did retire you know the the
great ones are always the ones that
don't know when to leave the party you
know the lights are on and the vacuum
cleaners are going and they're still
there at the bar and you know tom brady
can still sling it you know he can still
do it and he's taking a risk let's be
honest um you know he could have walked
away on top maybe not after the confetti
i think the thought was they wouldn't
win a super bowl in their first year but
maybe their second they kind of didn't
reverse right
um but the fact is is that you know
he could get hurt and we might you know
god forbid he looks like ben
roethlisberger at some point i mean
these are all things we don't know what
the last image of tom brady will be we
know what you know how he played in the
final game against the rams last year
but we don't know how this is going to
go and so he's taking a risk um but it's
a calculated one and i think that he's
pretty comfortable uh knowing the
landscape of the nfc especially the nfc
south they can absolutely win this
division but they have a brutal schedule
they play in germany they play a ton of
playoff teams cincinnati the rams um you
know baltimore all these teams and it's
going to be it's going to be a tougher
road this year they go you know it's not
going to be easy for them for sure
how does brady coming back change the
direction of this team if blaine
gabbard's the quarterback what is the
direction as opposed to tom brady
um downward i mean nothing against
playing like a rebuild
yeah well yep kind of i mean for sure i
think what they would have done um you
know look i know they were in the talks
for deshaun watson but bruce aries when
i talked to him yesterday said he he
just didn't think that was going to
happen now whether that's ownership or
compensation uh he was not confident
they were going to get deshaun watson so
they would have signed another free
agent you know whether that's teddy
bridgewater or somebody else to compete
with blaine and try to bring along kyle
trask i mean they like kyle trask he
just simply hasn't played he had a
redshirt year last year um barely got to
practice at times and so
kyle gets another another redshirt year
maybe he he progresses to be the backup
uh but i think
you know it would have looked totally
different and
you know and and some of these players
like ryan jensen may not have come back
and gronk wouldn't have come back and
and so i think
it's a it's a big difference between
rebuild and reload or remodel you know
they were saying remodel it was a
rebuild
when you when you're talking about the
quarterback position i mean look how
many teams are looking for them um you
know so from that standpoint i think
i think they did the right thing here
if i gave you one question to ask de
brady knowing that he would give you an
honest answer
what was the tipping point
what what was that moment right where
you said i have to play um you know i
know there's a lot of talk about his
family really the off-season was just
like it's always been you know he does a
lot of traveling spends a lot of time
with family there's a perception that
you know giselle wants him to quit maybe
she does um she's annoyed by that from
what i understand by the way that that's
not the case that you know she does not
want to be the one um to you know to
tell tom when he when he's supposed to
end his career because he loves what he
does there's concern obviously but he
loves what he does so i would just want
to know
what was that what was that clarity
moment that you had were you watching tv
did you you know did it annoy you when
russell wilson went you know uh from
seattle you know to denver i mean like
what was that moment that made you say
yeah you know what i'm coming back
because i know i can whip these guys
butts
well i guess i'll be seeing more of you
rick or you'll be seeing more of us but
uh thanks for joining us as always bun
hey send me a t-shirt man you know what
i'd love to get one what are the new
what are the new slogans now uh never
say never
never say definitely never say never are
you a large or extra large rick oh i'm
an extra-large yeah no doubt okay all
right we'll uh we'll take care of them
you need tv-12 you need to get on the
tb12 regimen
hey well now now i got a whole year to
do it again you know like we had kovit
we had all these things and i got my
calling alex guerrero so i'm ready to go
man thank you rick that's uh rick stroud
he covers the buccaneers for the tampa
bay times